We will now dig deeper into what needs to be done in the systems software stack
to support virtualization of the hardware resources for use by the
many operating systems living on top of
the hardware simultaneously. As you've seen in
the earlier course module, on operating system
extensibility. The question boils down to how
to be flexible while being performance conscious and safe. You'll
see that a bulk of our discussion on virtualization centers around
memory systems. The reason is quite simple, namely, memory hierarchy
is crucial to performance. Even efficient handling of
device virtualization is heavily reliant on how
memory system is virtualized and made available
to the operating systems running on top of
the hypervisor. So let's start with techniques for
virtualizing the memory management in a performance-conscious manner.